i think they made an amended complaint
make better allegations factually but
there is inferential evidence
that foughty pelosi and harris had
specifically
requested each of those platforms to
remove trump from those platforms
some of that's based on some of their
public statements some of that's based
on some of the emails that came out from
the foyer request with fauci and
zuckerberg
there's much more collusion some of that
is indirectly referenced by robert
kennedy's suit against facebook pending
in california
about the same set of allegations so i
think if they make better allegations
they may be able to get to the discovery
stage and find out
just how much these big tech giants were
operating at the direct request
of government actors
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
trial lawyer
and an all-star political gambler also a
primo promoter
of locals.com robert barnes welcome back
to the reuben report
glad to be here i am glad to have you
man i didn't realize until literally two
minutes ago that
we have not spoken uh you know
one-on-one forum
for over two years um
is the world getting better or worse in
those two years well you know back then
i was taking a lot of controversial
cases so it was you know alex we were
talking about alex jones the covington
kids wesley snipes ralph nader girls
gone wild all
the rest of it so i decided to take less
controversial cases so i took
donald trump during the elections uh amy
cooper in new york
kyle rittenhouse self-defense but yeah
the world just keeps getting crazier
particularly from a legal political
perspective
yeah so what put you on the map is it
fair to say that what originally sort of
put you on the map in a bigger sense
was the bet on trump is that really the
thing that kind of got you out there as
more of a public lawyer
yeah yeah i mean basically i'd always
been done a lot of tax work
but for a lot of reasons i didn't need
that to be high profile
and had done a lot of civil rights work
but had not made myself a public figure
but uh people had followed the trump bet
because it was a big bet and the rest he
became a public figure and during the
trump time period it became more
important
to be a public figure defending certain
issues in the court of public opinion
yeah and now you're an all-star youtuber
who hangs out like this all day
like world world come at me so i want to
get into some of those cases that that
you've covered obviously but let's start
with
with trump's current lawsuit because
just in the last you know 10 days or so
he has announced that
he's basically going after big tech in a
class action lawsuit and not just big
tech but actually some of the heads
of these companies so can you give
people the 101
the sort of must-have info on what the
lawsuit actually is and then we'll
talk about the chances of it succeeding
sure so basically trump has brought a
claim
saying that they all the big tech giants
conspired with
various government actors to kick him
off of and exclude him
from all of their platforms and he is
saying that they did so as state actors
and thus are subject to first amendment
limitations so that's the core of his
claim against google
against facebook and against twitter as
well as dorsey zuckerberg
and the google ceo individually so the
key there seems to be some kind of
collusion with the government he's not
arguing just that twitter facebook and
instagram all sat down and maybe did
something but somehow there was a
connection to the government
do you have any idea if there's evidence
of that or
or what he could actually prove that
would show it
i think they made an amended complaint
make better allegations
factually but there is inferential
evidence
that foughty pelosi and harris had
specifically requested
each of those platforms to remove trump
from those platforms
some of that's based on some of their
public statements some of that's based
on some of the emails that came out from
the foyer request with fouchy and
zuckerberg
there's much more collusion some of that
is indirectly referenced by robert
kennedy's suit against facebook pending
in california
about the same set of allegations so i
think if they make
better allegations they may be able to
get to the discovery stage and find out
just how much these big tech giants were
operating at the direct request
of government actors right so before we
get to discovery which obviously is the
interesting part of this
why is he doing it as a class action and
not just him going after them for how he
was
you know in his in his eyes uh you know
basically
wronged i think his purpose in this his
heart is in the right place
i think some of the lawyers involved
might not have the technical skill to
translate that well
because there could have been a class
action alleging that big tech is really
part of the public digital square
and the public square has just moved
from the physical world to the digital
world
and from the geographic world to the
online world and he would have had i
think a strong claim on that at least to
challenge existing law and to extend it
they didn't really do that so this
particular class action
isn't the strongest because what he's
alleging really is that he was targeted
because he was president trump
and he's trying to bring all these other
people in that have been targeted for
political reasons
but they're not president trump so from
a pure legal perspective technically
it's not the best claim
right so can you explain like kind of
just how the process works so he now
brings this class action
and how does it get to the judge and
like
is it one judge that will decide if this
thing can go to trial
effectively here's what's likely to
happen they'll likely try to move to
transfer it from the southern district
to florida where he filed it to the
northern district of california
on grounds that it's a term of service
dispute at least twitter
probably facebook and youtube will try
that as well they he'll that'll be his
fault
meaning you get it meaning you get it to
cali because that's where they're based
exactly yeah and if they and they have
some contractual language that
can depending on the nature of the claim
uh require that
if they say so they they're gonna want a
different district court judge assigned
and a different court of appeals they'll
want the ninth circuit not the 11th
circuit
they'll also want any slap law to apply
which doesn't apply in florida but it
would apply in california
because that would make trump
responsible for the other side's legal
fees
if he loses so that would be his first
big battle the second battle would be a
motion to dismiss before it ever gets to
class certification stage
if he wins at that level then he gets
discovery
and then after that a single judge
usually decides whether or not there's
class certification
so he's got several procedural hurdles
to get through first right so who
decides that part because it seems to me
that this thing
even if trump doesn't win if it at least
gets to discovery
we're gonna find out something you know
if twitter and facebook and youtube have
to open up the books
and really show oh members of congress
or the senate
were or the administration were actually
dming people about you know coordinating
some of this stuff or whatever else it's
showing related to
manipulating algorithms or shadow
banning or anything else it's like
that's the win even if it's not a legal
win so
how do we at least get there he
basically needs to enhance the complaint
so i think he should add some lawyers to
the team like alan dershowitz like
harmeet dillon harmy dylan is a very
good state action twitter claim
currently pending
so add some lawyers who are familiar
with this space
uh and change his complaint his cl
complaint as it currently exists
won't get him past a motion to dismiss
but if they add to it i think he has
good grounds to allege
that these these individual actors were
acting at the direct request
of vice president kamala harris and of
speaker of the house nancy pelosi and
maybe of anthony fauci in other contexts
and then i think you can get to
discovery and you're absolutely right
there's going to be a lot of revelatory
discovery
if he can get to that stage so i hope he
improves the case
so that he can get to that stage i sense
you think maybe he doesn't have the best
legal representatives around him right
now the way you're describing it
uh no the it's one of these groups
that's a dc-based group that their roots
are in sort of big oil corporate
lobbying
so they're you know if you wanted a
regulatory issue on
on energy they're fantastic first
amendment constitutional issue on big
tech that's not the area of focal point
so i think the these lawyers are lawyers
that are unfamiliar with this space and
it showed up in the suit
and right now those of us that are
familiar in this space that want this
lawsuit to move forward are very
concerned that as
alleged this lawsuit is as doa so he can
improve it though he's got plenty of
times to amend it
but with trump sometimes his personnel
picks gary a little hit or miss
right did you think about picking up the
phone and saying hey guys i know a
little something about this we have some
connections here
actually a bunch of us did and it's just
uh trump is trump
so you know he makes his decisions at
different times like uh you know the
i've been telling him ever since
actually november that uh he should be
on locals i mean
if you want to compete with uh all the
big tech people what better way to
monetize trump's brand
well i mean there's so many different
ways he could do this but he has a lot
of other people whispering in his ear
and i think some of the people that are
whispered in his ear don't really want
him to succeed in his suit
so i think that and it was a problem
throughout his four years that there was
some you know an
angel on one side on one shoulder a
devil on the other
and he doesn't always get the best
advice but people are telling him that
now so
i hope he takes corrective action before
the case can get dismissed
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversation about law
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our law
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell